dieu du tonnerre roi khan
vous avez finalement rejoint notre combat eh bien
ils disent mieux vaut tard que pas
seul c'est très bien
car vous savez que nous vivions dans une
oasis paisible mais ensuite nos dieux ont
été assassinés et maintenant notre
temple sacré a été laissé sans surveillance  et
j'espère que pour contrôler son pouvoir, c'est
notre sanctuaire le plus sacré et il
ne profanera pas longtemps le
roi, vous ne pouvez pas
leur dire ce qui s'est passé ici aujourd'hui,
dites-nous l'heure à laquelle thor
l'équipage hétéroclite desperados inadapté a
renversé la vapeur dans la bataille
et  ce sont leurs noms dans l'histoire, les
chances sont peut-être contre nous, mais je vais vous le dire
gratuitement ici, nous y allons
et
ici et maintenant
ils sont dans le royaume de l'ombre comment savez-vous
que
l'atmosphère là-bas a une obscurité pas comme les
autres c'est comme  si la couleur semble marcher,
c'est indubitable,
alors si c'est la couleur dont nous avons besoin
, apportons l'arc-en-ciel,
apportons l'arc-en-ciel avec son slogan
ou quelque chose qu'elle n'a été qu'un thor pendant
une minute, je veux dire sauver des vies, elle est assez
douée mais le reste  de cela, elle a besoin de
travail combien de slogans y a-t-il
eu beaucoup
ouais
saute le pistolet accroche-toi il se déplace à travers les
ombres et il va dans le royaume de l'ombre
il semble que c'est là qu'il
va être le plus puissant tu as
raison nous ne pouvons pas  va juste marcher là-
dedans ça pourrait être un piège est-ce que tu penses à ce que
je pense que tu penses que je pense
qu'est-ce qu'on pense qu'on en
prend trop
[Musique]
toi